The ominous song that struck fear into the hearts of millions around the world...
...means Squid Game is back,...
...the most popular series ever on Netflix.
This time for real.
Sort of.
A newly announced reality show...
...with 456 competitors and 4.56 million dollars at stake for the winner.
Sound familiar?
Squid Game: The Challenge comes amid struggles at Netflix.
Its stock price is down more than 70% so far this year...
...after the company announced a steep loss in subscribers.
They are looking to bring subscribers back.
What better way to do that than bring back the Squid Game audience?
They've also seen success in other reality shows,...
...so it's a great way to combine one audience with another...
...and hopefully bring in a whole new group of subscribers.
Perhaps an attempt to capitalize on the massive success...
...of the ultraviolent Korean-language thriller that swept the globe last fall.